at the costume Designers Awards you have
mentioned that you like to work on
period pieces because you can bring a
lot of your own ideas and creations to
the costumes you design and make what
were some of your inspirations for young
Victoria
oh goodness the inspirations were the
inspirations were the will the real
thing the real costumes and I was
fortunate enough to actually see some of
Victoria's real clothes they're archived
at Kensington Palace so I got to see
them so I started with that and looking
at portraiture from the period and then
I guess that was the inspiration then I
go ahead and design my versions of
things which are hopefully historically
accurate as far as we can we can get
them using contemporary materials and
things how surprised people been
discovered that that old frumpy Queen
Victoria that they pictured was this
young sexy woman and you got to design
what she want well I mean I I didn't
know anything about Victoria I didn't I
mean I mean my image of her was the old
frumpy woman in black you know and I
didn't really know that she might
officer she was young once but I didn't
know that she actually was vibrant and
attractive and a real character you know
she was a real sort of headstrong even
tomboyish woman so you know I'm glad
that we've been able to portray her as
something different and it's actually
interesting and people that people have
enjoying the movie and going to see it